hey guys were back with Josh for the
challenge you won Big Brother do you
think you'll ever win the challenge
I never dumped myself I go you know I go
into all these souls for the money I
don't go like I honestly don't sign up
for anything else but to win money yeah
and so every time I go in it's with the
intention to win and my mindset locked
in sometimes it doesn't work out but I
rather take that gamble and that risk
then you know play it safe so you go on
these shows to win money yeah also to
cause some drama because that you just
pulled to put up Wes yeah walk me
through that
what the hell Josh I've been waiting to
go in on this whole blindside cuz
everybody has their opinion on Twitter
everybody everybody from the house the
cast mates have something to say about
it so I've been waiting to do it
to this interview with you to go off but
so I'm gonna give you the juice I'm
gonna do you right now long story short
basically I walked into this game into
this season with a vendetta with Wes you
know he reached out to me my first
season you know all I got your back work
we're working in alliance and the second
he got a chance he was one of the votes
that voted me in so if I had any
problems coming into the season it was
with Wes was I gonna be vocal about it
no I was gonna blindside this out of him
and that's exactly what I did also he
just the way he you know wes is a great
guy outside of the game but he has this
persona that he turns into like this
egotistical mastermind and he is a
mastermind of the game but I just don't
do well with big egos like that and I
just feel like he needed to be humbled
to pull off then to live in a house with
people oh-hoo either a don't support it
or just like what the hell happened can
you not be trusted moving forward this
alliance I mean without saying too much
it that move in itself shifts how the
whole game turns out to play out it just
completely it sets the tone for how
everything's about to go down within the
next few episodes and with how the
season plays out I think that you know
there was a lot of people what people
don't get is that people walk into these
shows it's not like big brother
we're one and done they have friendships
they have alliances West came in with a
huge alliance and I saw those numbers
and they offered me either to be in that
alliance or go against it there was no
way I was ever gonna be loyal to him so
I couldn't you know I played ball for a
bit but there was no way that I was
gonna stay true to that alliance and
stay loyal to it so I think taking that
shot just sets the tone for so many more
I'm getting in trouble for this but like
game big moves that are gonna go down
yeah Laurel Laurel Ally you know when
Laurel I think that with past seasons
you see just like the tough side of her
she's I mean she's a badass competitor
but I think that with her we hit it off
right from the start we build a good
friendship and then I think if anybody
was gonna make that move I knew it was
gonna be her I had before I was even at
a tribe you know I had it I was like you
know what I might take the shot at West
but I late I didn't show my cards I
didn't say a word I kept it you know
quiet and then as soon as Laurel came at
me with it I was like dawn it's actually
read my mind I was like let's do it so
um I think that there's nobody else that
I would have picked him make that move
with and I'm happy I still stand by till
Thursday yeah you still love that move
oh hell yeah people are mad about it
people are pissed but at the end of the
day there was no loyalty in Team America
you know these people hate each other
they were talking every day Polly wanted
to take a shot at Johnny in my ear
Johnny wanted to take a shot at West so
it's like I just so happen to be the one
to make the first move you got me and
with that move either it could mess me
up
moving forward or set me up moving
forward yes because holly was like your
big brother friend and you know this
season I'm starting to see that you're
getting a little annoyed with lolly I
could tell that just like two episodes
in episodes and you're just like you
really ain't here for Polly yeah why I
think with Polly
all right so with Polly visit I think
Paulie it's like you can't have a
friendship unless you're listening to
what the guy wants it's either his way I
think what Paulie and Cara it's um
either you got a kissed or you got to
listen to what they want in that game
Paulie outside of the house he's a cool
dude in that game he gets you know
really controlling I think he turns into
like a mini West and I just every time I
think a real friendship like we could
disagree and still have a good
friendship with him it's not like that
it's like either you listen to me and
what I'm telling you to do or nothing's
gonna work out and then I think you're
gonna see our friend it's you know with
this move and with how the game plays
out you're gonna definitely see some
cracks and me and him go head to head
with in not had to have yeah it's it's
gonna get ugly and at the other day like
I don't back down from anybody so it's
gonna it's gonna be inside yeah yeah it
gets ugly with Paulie yeah what are the
differences between big brother and the
challenge like what makes the challenge
more challenging it's more cutthroat you
know the big brother is cutthroat but
Thursdays you know the everybody keeps
it friendly you know I think with the
challenge is way more cutthroat
everybody's it's like a savage they're
just savage it's like they don't care
there's no you know there's no sympathy
empathy nothing they don't care like if
they hurt you it's like all right go cry
in a corner nobody gives you know so I
think it within coming into my second
season it just it put me in that same
mindset of like I'm going to war trust
no one
you know play your game do you and
that's how I came into the season
wanting to play like that I feel like
what the challenge is you get to film
then go home and watch oh yeah how is
that like eating it does it make you
happy
oh yeah because you're reliving
everything and then you see the opinions
of fans I think that to be honest with
you I wish it was like Big Brother where
we get out and then it's done come not
done I mean people are still invested in
talking about it but we're not seeing it
in action
where as in now it's like you get over
something you make up with your cast
mates and then the season airs and it's
like oh it's back at it again you know
just like you picked off where you
dropped off and it sucks um but you know
that's what makes their soul so good
that it
like continued rivalries and people
continue to come back with past drama
and yeah if you could tell me two people
from this season that you absolutely
cannot stand who would those two people
be Cara Maria 100% really can't stand
her she was a very toxic person to work
with within a team okay I think she's a
great competitor she's proved that I
just think within a team dynamic you
just she was driver her at all I don't
person who just can't stand and another
person would have to be oh I don't want
to say west' cuz I sent him home already
but you can say west' I would say well
yeah so last time you were here Johnny
Bananas you guys weren't really on you
know the good page but right now you
just took out it like your arch nemesis
and his arch nemesis yeah is it a matter
of your enemy as my enemy in our cool I
think in that house it is a hundred
percent yeah I think it's like if you
have a common enemy you become best
friends in Sallee that's right we're not
best friends but listen Johnny's a great
guy to be lost now Johnny's actually a
really cool dude we we build a good
friendship going into the season and it
continues on the show and I think that
he's one of those people that did have
my back and I think that that's
definitely an alliance and a friendship
that's going to form and you guys gonna
see play out as the season goes on but
um you know people are saying that
Johnny influenced my move or I did
Johnny's move if me targeting and Wes if
we have that in common it's just that
makes West a bad guy like you know it
doesn't really make it just so happens
to be that we both alright so Wes
brought Johnny and Josh closer together
look at that who'da thought thanks
mister thanks as your friend it's so
stressful watching you like I have no
more edges left I'm wearing a wig today
because of it well we see you pull more
of my hair out like play a little bit
more safer and it's falling off okay
yeah it's gonna get intense it's it's a
good season so I'm excited for you All
Right see you playoffs well Thank You
Josh again for being here with us for
talking to us whenever Josh comes in I'm
just a good
I wait I wait to go off in our interview
very good it was pretty good
you're pretty good